FEMALE SPEAKER: So now we're
going to shift, and we're
going to hear an amazing talk by
a hardware lead at Google.
Jean Wang has a PhD
in electrical
engineering in photonics.
She worked in the optical
communications and
then came to Google.
She's the hardware lead
on Google Glass.
As a board member, I
have Google Glass.
I love it.
It's so much more natural
than a phone.
And now you get to hear about
how she did this.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JEAN WANG: Hi, everybody.
Smile.
So I'm very happy to be
here with you today.
I'd like to share with
you my Glass journey.
It's a three-part story that
spans across multiple domains.
And while it is yet unfinished,
I hope you share
my enthusiasm for what
is yet to come.
Before diving in, I'd actually
like to float this number
briefly and plant it
in your minds.
It has significance to me and
the story, and in the
meantime, please feel free
to question the number
base that I'm using.
So, Glass, like many ideas,
started as a blank canvas.
As part of the initial team,
we came into the project
largely inexperienced
in the field of
head-mounted displays.
Instead, we had the ability to
divide and conquer through our
ability to learn and adapt.
While some of us focused on
optics, like myself, others
worked on cameras, sensor
systems, electronics.
And so we also came in with the
fundamental belief that
technology had ripened to the
point where we can make a
significant impact and create
something of significant use.
And that has led us into the
discovery phase, to find out
just what it was that could be
done to basically minimize the
barrier to information access,
and to make us connect with
each other in terms of accessing
our social sphere.
As part of the discovery
process, we looked at existing
products in the mobile space
and wanted to really
understand where it was that we
can make an impact in terms
of form factor.
For example, whether it was
bulky and had to fit into our
pocket or carry around a bag
for it; ease of access,
whether we had to pull it out
of our pocket or a bag to
actually engage with it; and
also ease of use, whether we
were blocked when we were using
the device, or whether
we could look straight ahead and
talk with people and not
be distracted.
So to push on these pain points,
we did a number of
technical experiments.
Here's a helmet-mounted display
that did not allow us
to be hands free
or wires free.
And in the bottom, you can see
here, is an early optical
experiment to help us understand
the technical
complexities in terms of how
optics sizes actually impact
the performance and
the image quality.
So with these considerations
in mind, we dived into
selecting components that
we could use to
make a viable solution.
So in the vast array of options,
we looked at what it
was we could just reuse
and customize.
Or was there something that we
had to invent for ourselves?
So we played around with a bunch
of pico projectors and
projectors.
We looked at optic components
such as lenses and prisms as
well as interface devices--
touch pads, microphones,
speakers.
And underpinning the whole
system was electrical
components and board design.
So in this huge selection of
choices and huge array of
options, how do we
down-select?
And so we filtered using
two key criteria.
One was power consumption,
and a second was weight.
So these two are basically
factors in enabling us to
first, wear a system all day,
and second, actually allow us
to want to wear a
system all day.
So we headed into the second
phase of prototyping.
Here are six example generations
of glass
prototypes.
Starting at the very top left,
we took the lowest hanging
fruit of simply putting mobile
phones to the side of the
head, and a pico projector
shining directly into the eye
to provide the image.
And so this was a bit bulky,
as you can imagine.
It came in at 167 grams.
And we wisely decided that we
could lighten the load by
taking the mechanicals
off the phone.
And that's our second proto
shown right up there in the
middle top.
And so as you can see, over
time, we shifted from using
off-the-shelf components, such
as safety shields and frames,
into 3D printing
our own frame.
And that's shown here
in the third.
And you can also see that we
migrated into making our own
optical design and architecture,
which is
something we carry
through today.
And as you gradually evolve to
the very end, you see that
more and more we use customized
components.
And we look at making our own
plastics and metals to get to
where we are today, which is
essentially the essence of
what Glass needs to be.
This provides the core, and
provides a very minimalistic
system, that allows us to run
around and be happy when we're
playing with the system.
And in addition to prototyping
with the hardware, Glass
derives its use from
easy to follow UI.
And this is by definition
actually easy to make.
Along the way, we experimented
with a number of different
interaction concepts, for
example, head gestures.
And that recent SNL skit was not
too far from our previous
truth, if you've seen it.
Also, we experimented with
porting the keyword
functionality to the touchpad.
But we found that was a bit too
complex, even when running
in a predictive word mode.
We also tuned the number
of lines of text--
the font, the size--
to basically optimize
for readability.
So through all of these
things, we found that
minimalizing and stripping down
to the very core allowed
for the best use case
and experience.
We also found that minor head
tilts and voice commands
allowed us for hands-free
experience, which is very
important when we're
busy dancing or
riding that roller coaster.
On the flip side, having the
touchpad and the camera button
allowed us for more quiet
modes of interaction.
So with the hardware and
software solutions converging
into a viable state, the team
actually turned to the
question of production.
It is possible to manually tweak
and baby one device, to
get it to be close to ideal
in terms of cosmetics and
functionality.
However, we'd like to share
Glass more broadly.
And so that, to us,
quickly turns into
the question of scale.
How do we build not 1, 1,000,
100,000, but upward towards a
googol of devices?
Layering in automation
is key to this.
And that means that not only
do we have to build Glass
itself, but we have to build
infrastructure that builds Glass--
this floor space, the
equipment, the
whole kit and caboodle.
And to add a bit more
complexity, we'd like to honor
individuality and human
preferences.
And that to us, has meant color
options, and that leads
to color complexity.
How do we make sure that on
the device itself, part to
part, the colors match?
And how do we make
sure that between
devices the colors match?
So production requires the
solutions to all of these
questions and beyond.
Through these three phases of
discovery, prototyping, and
production, I have found that
Glass is both an innovation
and a reinvention.
By integrating highly compact
and new components, we've been
able to extend far beyond nickel
head-mounted displays,
beyond the last couple decades
of individualized movie
players, game consoles,
and aircraft systems.
On other hand, I think that
Glass is a way in which we can
examine and develop new fields
that we can push beyond and
learn to be better connected to
each other as well as share
perspective and have access
to information.
And all of this will allow us to
better empathize as people
and sympathize.
So coming back to that number
at the very beginning.
It's been exactly, as
of today, 1,111
days since I joined.
And this is a picture I
would not be able to
take without Glass.
I am paragliding over Coronet
Peak, New Zealand.
And just by looking at it, I can
recall what it was like to
soar with the birds
and to take in the
beauty of the landscape.
I have often been asked what the
a-ha moments have been in
the project thus far.
And while I have a few, I
am more excited about
what is yet to come.
There is a first tier, for
example, a bar code, QR code
scans, where we can get
just-in-time reviews of
movies, books, that menu trace
we're just about to take, but
we're not quite sure yet.
Then there's also never getting
lost and not bumping
into things while you're
looking at directions.
And then there's a whole
other level.
Recently one of my colleagues
exchanged his wedding vows
while wearing the device.
And I get goose bumps when I
imagine him reliving that when
he is old and gray and seeing
the reflection of a future
from his wife's eyes.
And then there's also a
physics instructor who
recently toured CERN
with the device.
And he did a Hangout back to
his classroom in Michigan.
And he was riding his bike down
the tunnel of the Large
Hadron Collider showing his
classroom just how cool it
was, while taking live questions
on the spot.
Then there's also another
example where Glass can mean
life or death, that it can
help you translate to a
medical doctor in a foreign
country that you're allergic
to penicillin.
So through this process, I think
that there's just so
much potential in what is yet
to come, that in pushing
towards a new perspective on
information sharing and
perspective sharing, we've come
upon a new environment
Glass can engender.
And when I have time to pause
and think about how far we've
come, I feel privileged to be
part of such a dynamic team.
Together we're striving forth
to bring forward this new
perspective.
And I count you, as developers,
as part of this
growing group.
There's just so much potential
and positive impact in keeping
in the moment, where information
is just at your
fingertips and knowledge is
a twinkle in your eye.
And with that I look forward
to your aha moments, and we
are back to discovery.
[APPLAUSE]
JEAN WANG: Thanks everyone.